[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمول
وفي الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من السودان وهذه الصور من ام
درمان التي تشهد اليوم تبادلا للقصف
المدفعي في المنطقه الفاصله بين الطرفين
حاربين في وسط المدينه وشرقها
وهذه الصور مباشره من واشنطن حيث عقدت
لجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب اولى جلساتها
المتعلقه بالمزاعم بشان علاقه الرئيس جو
بايدن للانشطه الماليه لنجله هنتر في مسعى
يهدف الى محاكمته برلمانيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
البرهان يكلف اعضاءا في مجلس السياده
بالاشراف على الوزارات والهيئات الحكوميه
تفرض عقوبات على وزير سابق للخارجيه
وشركتين مرتبطتين بقوات الدعم السريع
وتتهمهم بتقويض الامن وعرقله الانتقال
الديمقراطي في السودان
تزامنا مع لجوء اكثر من نصف سكان اقليم
كاراباخ الى ارمينيا سلطات ارمن الاقليم
تعلن حل نفسها
يصف الوضع بالتطهير العرقي واذربيجان
تتهمه بعرقله الادماج وتؤكد التزامها
بمجتمع متعدد الاثنيات
استمرار اجواء الحداد في العراق وعزاء
جماعي في ضحايا حريق الحمدانيه
السلطات ترجع سبب الحادث للتقصير والاهمال
وتتوعد بمحاسبه المسؤولين
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا توقيع وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيليه اتفاقا لبيع منظومه صواريخ
ارواحيت ثلاثه لالمانيا في اكبر صفقه من
نوعها في تاريخ الصناعات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي بعد توقيع اسرائيل
اكبر صفقه لصناعتها العسكريه تتضمن بيع
منظومه صواريخ اروحيتس ثلاثه مات قيمكم
لهذه الخطوه من جانب المانيا اربعه
وثلاثون في المئه رجحوا رغبه برلين في
مواجهه تداعيات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
بينما قال 30% ان ذلك جزء من التوجه
الالماني لتعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه وصوت
36% لصالح خيار وجود تقارب الماني
اسرائيلي
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
لجنه برلمانيه بريطانيه تطالب الحكومه
بحمايه صانعي الموسيقى من تاثير مطوري
تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
في احدث تطورات السودان فرضت الولايات
المتحده عقوبات على وزير الخارجيه
السوداني السابق في عهد البشير علي كرتي
وشركتين احداهما مقرها روسيا بتهمه مفاقمه
عدم الاستقرار في البلاد وخلال الساعات
الاخيره تبادل الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع القصف المدفعيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
وشهدت مناطق من المدينه مواجهات بين
الطرفين
سياسيا اعلن رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان تكليف اعضاء من المجلس بالاشراف
على الوزارات الحكوميه في البلاد
وتضمنت قائمه المكلفين شخصيات معروفه في
المجلس
معارك مستعره في الخرطوم وضواحيها وقررت
مهمه للبرهان من بورتسودان ما لا يتغير في
العاصمه السودانيه منذ خمسه اشهر هو عزيز
الرصاص ودخان القصي بين الاخوه الاعداء
سمع دوي في جره متتاليه خلال الساعات
الاخيره في مركز المدينه وتحدثت مصادر عن
تحليق كثيف لطائره الجيش شرقي المدينه
ذكرت ان قوات الدعم السريع قصفت بالمدفعيه
مواقع الجيش عند نقطه جبل اولياء جنوبي
الخرطوم لم تسلم مدينه ام درمان من
مواجهات بين الطرفين المتحاربين في بلد
ينزف بسبب هذا الصراع وما قبله من ازمات
كبيره وكثيره تكلفه جديده لاسماء معروفه
اعلنها رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان يتضمن القرار اشراف اعضاء مجلس
السياده على شؤون الوزارات الحكوميه في
البلاد وقد كلف البرهان نائبه مالك
بالاشراف على عدد من الوزارات من بينها
الطاقه والنفط والتربيه والتعليم والثقافه
والاعلام والتنميه الاجتماعيه والصحه
والتعليم العالي بينما اسندت الى عضو مجلس
السياده شمس الدين كباشي مهام الاشراف على
وزاره الداخليه والخارجيه والعدل والري
والموارد المائيه ورئاسه مجلس الوزراء
بموجب القرار سيتولى ياسر العطاء شؤون
وزاره الدفاع والماليه وبنك السودان
المركزي بينما سيشرف عضو المجلس السيادي
ابراهيم جابر على وزاره الزراعه والثروه
الحيوانيه والتجاره والصناعه والاستثمار
والتعاون الدولي والاتصالات والنقل يطرح
القرار تساؤلات عن اليه اداره تلك
الوزارات والمؤسسات بعيدا عن الخرطوم
عاصمه البلد الغارق في الفوضى وكانحر سيف
العقوبه الامريكيه لم يغب عن تطورات
المشهد السوداني الكثير التعقيدات هذه
الشهور
وزاره الخزانه انها استهدفت علي كرتي وزير
الخارجيه السابق الذي اصبح زعيما للحركه
الاسلاميه السودانيه بعد الاطاحه بالبشير
عام 2019 كما فرضت العقوبات ايضا على
وهي شركه مقرها السودان تتهمها واشنطن
بانها تستخدم وسيله مشتريات لقوات الدعم
السريع استنادا لبيان الخزانه فهذه الشركه
كانت تنسق مع شركه الامدادات العسكريه
ايفيا تريد ومقرها روسيا والتي استهدفتها
هذه العقوبات الازمه الانسانيه بكل
تفاصيلها المروعه والمرعبه تزيد مع كل يوم
اخر السودان محروم فيه من الاستقرار
الامني والسياسي اكثر من سته ملايين
سوداني على بعد خطوه واحده من المجاعه
تستغيث الامم المتحده تفشي الكوليرا وحم
الضنك يزيد المشهد المزرقه تامه مع بدء
الامطار الموسميه وانهيار القطاع الصحي
بسبب الصراع الاكثر تضررا ولايات القضارف
والبحر الاحمر وشمال كردفان والخرطوم
تتعدد اسباب الاوبئه ومنها تلوث مياه
الشرب من جثث غير مدفونه ومن النفايات من
كل النواحي وعلى مد الجغرافيا الشاسعه
السودان ليس بخير وشعبه تضيق به سبل
الحياه شبه الطبيعيه
الينا من زيوريخ الدكتور عبد الباقي شحتو
علي الباحث السوداني والاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه وينضم الينا من بورسودان الدكتور
محي الدين محمد محي الدين الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومعك سيد محي الدين سنبدا ماذا
يريد
البرهان من وراء هذه الخطوه تكليف اعضاء
في مجلس السياده الاشراف على الوزارات
القصد هو اداره شان الدوله في ظل ظروف
الحرب لان السودان مواجه بحرب وانت تعلم
ان الحروب تحتاج الى
تكامل ادوار مؤسسات الدوله ما يعرف بقوه
دوله الشامله كلها تكون جزء من هذه
العمليه السودان الان مواجه بتحدي امني
يتضاءل بشكل كبير من خلال العمليات
العسكريه وانحسار قدرات
الميليشيا المتمرده على احداث اي تحولات
كبيره في المشهد العسكري ولكن في الاتجاه
الاخر هناك مشكلات تتعلق بتوفير الخدمات
ومعالجه قضايا المواطنين السودانيين بسبب
نزوح ملايين منهم من العاصمه الخرطوم الى
ولايه السودان المختلفه وبالتالي هذا
القرار يصب في اتجاه تفعيل اجهزه الدوله
التي
خرجت كثير اجهزه في الدوله وكيف الحرب كيف
ستفعل هذه الاجهزه وكيف سيتم الاشراف على
هذه الوزارات بعيدا عن الخرطوم من
بورسودان
ما الاشراف الاشراف غير الاداره يعني هناك
من يشرف على على هذه الوزارات تفعيل
التنسيق بينها ترابط ادواره لانه زي ما
ذكرنا قوه الدوله الشامله في الحروب يجب
ان تكون كلها متعارضه ومتازره في عملها
وبالتالي الاشراف لتفعيل اليات التكامل
بين مؤسسات الدوله المختلفه وزاراتها سيد
شحته كيف يقرا الدعم السريع
هذا الاجراء الذي اتخذه البرهان
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اخ حسن ويعطيك
الكرام
الحقيقه انا كزول باحث بننظر بان الخطوه
اللي جنبها برهان بخطوه خطيره جدا
واستفزازيه
يعني الاخ محمد حمدان دقله وكانت ذكر في
خطابه بانه اذا قامت حكومه في بورسودان
هذا يؤدي الى قيام حكومه في في الخرطوم
وهذا يعني بمشي به يذهب بنا الى سيناريو
اليمن وليبيا وهذا شيء مؤسف جدا بالاضافه
لانه تكوين حكومه بهذا الشكل يعني تاكيد
لمساله
الانقلاب
وظهور الاخوه اللي كانوا مع اخونا البشير
لسدت الحكم
وهذا ايضا يعني
يطيح
باتفاقيه جوى خاصه بعد
الاخوان الاتنين في المجلس
السيادي انا افتكر خطوه استفزازيه وخطيره
جاءت برضو للفشل الكبير اللي حصل بعد
زياره الاخ البرهان الى الى نيويورك كنت
اتمنى بانه اخونا البرهان يكون الاكثر
تعقلا بانه ننتظر معا
الاتفاقيه في في جده ونسمع لدور الجوار
حتى لا يتغسم السودان لان تقسيم السودان
هذا يعد له خطوره كبيره جدا للاخوه في مصر
كلها والحساب التفريقي نعم يعني ما ذكرته
في البدايه هل نفهم منه بان
قائد الدعم السريع
قد يلجا الى الاعلان عن حكومه مقابله في
الخرطوم مثلا في مواجهه
الحكومه من بورسودان
اعتقد ذلك مع هذه بتلكا
ناس بيتحدثون بان الدعم السريع يعني وهو
قوه عسكريه وانشات بقانون وهو معروف ولكن
اما التجرين بانها وغير ماليزيا طبعا
متروك للاخوه في الجيش او الطرف الاخر
اكيد حيقوم باعلان حيكون في المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها وليس الخطوره ما في كذا فقط
يعني هنالك اخوان اخرين عبد العزيز يعني
يتحكم على منطقه جزر كبير في جنوب كردفان
واخوان عبد الواحد في منطقه جبل مره وهذا
انا افتكر هذا شيء خطير بدلا ان نرجع يعني
بعد كل هذه المده
قربنا السته شهور بان الحرب يعني طحنت
الشعب السوداني مازال الاخوه متمسكين
بالسلطه بعد يعني
التضحيات الكبيره وهذا شيء مؤسف اخي
الكريم
سيد محي الدين
يعني في شق اخر ايضا من تطورات السودان له
علاقه بفرض بالولايات المتحده عقوبات على
وزير الخارجيه الاسبق علي كارتي بصفته كما
تقول الولايات المتحده يقود حركه متطرفه
تمنع الوصول الى اتفاق سلام كيف قرات هذا
القرار اضافه الى ايضا العقوبات على
شركتين تدعمان الدعم السريع
النقطه الاولى دايره ارد على حديث الضيفك
الكريم الحكومات تنشا لتقديم خدمات
للمواطنين المواطنين موجودون في الولايات
السودان المختلفه وبالتالي وجود حكومه اذا
كان في بورسودان او في غيره من مناطق
السودان ضروره ملحه ولا ليست مجالا للسجال
السياسي على نسق الحديث عن ان الدعم
السريع يمكن ان يشكل حكومه في الخرطوم هو
ينتهك الحرمات المواطنين هو موجود في
منازل المواطنين في المستشفيات فاي حكومه
يعني ما الحكومه اصلا تقوم لخدمه الشعب
والشعب الان ملتل به من قبل الميليشيا
المتمرده اعتقد ان هذا الامر يعني يعني
دعني اسميه سخيف يعني لا يمكن ان يتم
المقارنه بين القوات المسلحه والحكومه
القائمه الان التي تقدم خدمات المواطنين
ومن ينتهك حقوق المواطنين ويرهبهم فيما
يتصل بحديثك عن
الاتهامات للسيد علي كرتي ول
التابعات للدعم السريعا اعتقد ان هذه
مضاغطه من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لفرض
حلول
برؤيه معينه من خلال
منبر جده الذي تشارك فيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
واضح جدا انه هذه الضغوط
لحمل القوات المسلحه للقبول باتفاق معه او
اللقاء مع قوات الدعم السريع المتمرده
وهذا الامر لا تقدره الولايات المتحده حق
تقديره لان هذا الامر
خطورته في ان هذه القضيه ستطيل امد الحرب
لانه الشعب السوداني موقفه واضح من
الميليشيا المتمرده يعتقد ان عودتها ستعني
تاجيل معركه لمرحله قادمه وهذا الامر
اعتقد ان الشعب السوداني لا يمكن ان يتقبل
راي السيد شحته في هذا الموضوع موضوع
العقوبات ايضا وفي موضوع الحكومه الثانيه
مقر الحكومه الثانيه اذا قرر الدعم السريع
ان ان ينشاها وماذا يعني ذلك على الصعيد
الميداني تفضل السيد شحته
ممكن جدا للاخوه في الدعم السريع يقيموا
حكومه في المناطق التي سيطرون عليها اما
في يد بانهم في بيوت الناس وينتهكون
الحرمات الجيش السوداني مما انشئ كان
يحارب فقط الشعب السوداني وحاربنا نحن في
المناطق التي تسمى مهمه او الاكثر تخلفا
زمن طويل وحتى الدعم السريع حينما انشاه
الجيش كان يستخدمه جميع لضربه الحركات
المسلحه ولكنه ان هذا الدعم السريع الى
انحاز الدعم السريع الى
الثوره الشعبيه
لكن اجبني على السؤال رجاء
ان شاء الله هذا مقدر للاخوه القياده في
الدعم السريع اما موضوع العقوبات انا
افتكر الحكومات الحكومه الامريكيه
والمجتمع الدولي تاخر كثيرا في مساعده
المواطنين السودان يعني كان من من
بدري يعني تقوم هذه العقوبات
لمجموعات معروفه هي ارهابيه وهي ظاهره
بكتائب البراء واخونا علي كرتي ربنا يعني
يهديه بانه انا افتكر دوله انتهت لانه
الشعب السودان اتكلموا على الشعب السوداني
الشعب السوداني
بالثوره واعطاها بالبشيره لشعب السوداني
يعني في بعض الناس بيفتكروا الشعب
السوداني الا الشعب السوداني فالعقوبات
اللي حصلت اما بالنسبه للدعم السريع
الشركات التي يقال بان تسلح الدعم السريع
وغيره
هذه الشركات كان يتعامل معها جيش السوداني
يعني المعامله بتاع العقودات القديمه
ولازم الفكره سيد عبد الباقي شافته علي
البحث السوداني
في العلاقات الدوليه من زيورخ
وشكرا ايضا
للضيفنا الدكتور محي الدين محمد محي الدين
الكاتب والمحلله السودانيين من بورسودان
[موسيقى]
بعد ثلاثه عقود
يسدل يسدل ارمن كربا ستار على جمهوريتهم
المعلنه من طرف واحد فقد وقع زعيم ارمن
الاقليم مرسوما يحل سلطات الاقليم
ومؤسساته مع بدايه العام المقبل ودع زعيم
ارمني كراباخ سكان الاقليم الموجودين
داخله او خارج الى التعرف على شروط
الاندماج داخل دوله اذربيجان
انتهى حلم ارمني اقليم كرباخ باستمرار ما
سموه جمهوريه
في اقليم كارباخ اصدر مرسوما بحل السلطات
والمؤسسات فيه بدءا من مطلع 2024 وطبعا
تسليم السلاح بهذا تطوى صفحه بقعه جغرافيه
لطالما كانت بركانا خامدا يثور كل حين
مشعلا معه الصراع بين ارمينيا ودربيجان
اذا عادت الارض لئذربيجان ويتجه قسم كبير
من سكانها الارمن نحو ارمينيا ودافعهم
مخاوف تراكمه عبر عقود من نزاع مسلح
بدات قصه اقليم كارباخ البالغه مساحته
قرابه 4000
عقب انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي عام 91
واستقلال كل من ارمينيا ودربيجان بادرت
ارمينيا بالهجوم وضم اقليم كرباخ الى
سلطتها مع سبع مناطق اذربيجانيه اخرى عام
92 اعلن ارمن اقليم كاراباخ استقلاله
واقامه ما سمي جمهوريه ارتساخ وعاصمتها
استباناكيرت لم يعترف بها احد حتى ارمينيا
نفسها
عام 93 اصدر مجلس الامن قرارا ادان احتلال
ارمينيا لاقليم كارباخ واكد انه جزء من
اراضي اذربيجان مع ذلك لم تتوقف الحرب حتى
عام 94 بتوقيع الطرفين اتفاقا لوقف اطلاق
النار ظل الاقليم بعدها بسنوات يعيش حاله
الحرب ولا سن اشتباكات وقصف متبادل او
معارك قصيره الامد حتى حسم الجيش
الاذربيجاني هذه القضيه العالقه بسيطرته
على الاقليم واعادته لضرب جان انتهت
حسابات الجغرافيا والتاريخ والسلطه لاقليم
كراباخ لصالح اذربيجان اما ارمينيا فتشير
تصريحات مسؤوليها ان احداث اقليم كرباخ
الاخيره ستكون نقطه بدايه لاعاده النظر في
حسابات السياسه والتحالفات
ومع استمرار موجات النزوح من اقليم
كاراباخ قال رئيس الوزراء الامنيين كول
باشنيان انه لن يبقى اي ارمنيا في الاقليم
في غضون ايام واعتبر باشنيان في تصريحات
او ردتها وكاله انتر فاكس الروسيه انما
يجري في اقليم كاراباخ تطهير عرقي وتاجير
مضيفا ان ذلك ما كانت بلاده تحذر العالم
منه
في المقابل دانه الخارجيه لذربيجانيه بشده
ما وصفتها بمحاوله ارمينيا تضليل المجتمع
الدولي كما دانت الوزاره تصريحات باشنيان
واعتبرت في بيان ان باشيان يعطل جهود
اذربيجان في المساعده الانسانيه وعمليه
اعاده الادماج ودعت الخارجيه الاذربيجانيه
السكان الارمن الى عدم مغادره منازلهم
متعهده بالحفاظ على مجتمع اذربيجان متعدد
الاثنيات على حد تعبيرها
ينضموا الينا من يريفانا الدكتور الكسندر
ماركا روف مدير الفرع الارمني لمعهد رابطه
الدول المستقله ومن باكو ينضم الينا فؤاد
شيراكوف نائب مدير مركز دراسات جنوب
القوقاز معك ضيفنا من ياريتانا الكسندر
نبدا
يعني لم يكن من الافضل
للسكان الارمن في كاراباخ ان يبقوا حيث هم
ويندمجوا في المجتمع الاذربيجاني مدامه في
الارض التي ولدوا وتربوا فيها
الارض الذين كانوا يعيشون في وطنهم
لقرون من الزمن
يحاولون تقييم ما كان ينبغي ان
يتوقعوه من الدوله التي
يفترض انهم يندمجون فيها سجل دوله
اذربيجان وخاصه في الماضي القريب بقتل
السكان المدنيين وفرض حصار لمده اشهر
وحرمانهم من الطعام
والدعم الطبي لا يعد بمستقبل واعد للبقاء
ضمن دوله اذربيجان
كاقليه عرقيه ارمنيه صغيره يمكن ان تعيش
بسلام ومن حيث الاساس هذه المقاربه جانب
الدوله
الاذربيجانيه حياله الاقليه الارمنيه لا
تعدوا بان هناك وجودا سلميا لهذه الاقليه
ان يكون
عفوا
اذا كان ما تقوله صحيحا اذا كان ما تقوله
صحيحا فذلك كانت له ظروفه بمعنى ان ظروف
الانفصال والاستقلال واعلان
جمهوريه ربما كانت هذه العوامل هي التي
دفعت الى التصرف الاذربيجاني مع ارمن
الاقليم بهذا الشكل اذا كنت يعني اذا ما
كان قولك صحيحا لكن الان الظروف اختلفت
يعني الان كل هذه الظروف
انتفت وبالتالي ما المانع من بقاء الارمن
داخل اذربيجان وان يندمجوا في المجتمع
انا لا اتفق مع تسميه الارمن داخل كارباخ
بانهم انفصالين هم استخدموا حقهم في تقرير
المصير واقامه دولتهم الخاصه
ويعيشوا ضمن القوانين التي يفضلونها
لانفسهم اذا بالنسبه للارمن كان هذا خيالا
اختاروه على مدى 30
عاما وطبقوا حقهم في دوله هم اعلنوها من
طرفهم
وايضا
ان يكونوا تحت حكم اداره وحكومه هم
ينتخبونها بانفسهم هم كانوا يفضلون لهذا
الاستقلال ان يتم الاعتراف به وان يكون هو
الوعد الافضل لمستقبلهم طبعا اي ارمله
اخرين داخل الذروه دوله اذربيجانيه الذين
كانوا يعيشون ليس في اقليم
ولكن في اماكن اخرى هل كان ممكنا لهم ان
يعيشوا ربما بعض الذين كانوا يعيشون في
قرباق سيقتنعون بان هذا ممكن لكن ما
رايناه انه لم يبقى اي ارمني في اجزاء او
اخرى من اذربيجان اسمح لي اسمع راي السيد
فؤاد هنا من من باكو سيد فؤاد اذا المشكله
ليست في ان الارمن لا يريدون البقاء في
كارباخ المشكله ان دوله اذربيجان لا
تريدهم ولا تريد ارمني على اراضيها كما
يقول ضيفنا من يريدان
اولا
اود ان نصحح زميلي حتى
قبل نشوف الحرب الثانيه فانه علق الاربعين
الفني غادر البلاد لدينا قائمه باسمائهم
وكل اوصافهم والان هناك ناس مسنون وتجيل
المعمرين
ولدينا اشرت فيديو واشرطه صوت
لا يمكن نكران وجود وجود ارمن في اذربيجان
اولا واذا هذا يدل على النبي بامكان ان
يعيشوا ضمن المجتمع
وقد عاشوا فيه فعلا واستطاعوا العيش فيه
اضافه لذلك
فان اذربيجان على خلافه وعلى عكس
ارمينيا التي بلغت عرقيه واحده الدوله
الوحيده ذات عرق واحد في هذه المنطقه في
حين ان اذربان متعدده
القوميات والاعراق وهو بلد خلال الحرب
الاولى الحرب الثانيه
كان هناك
عفوا
مختلفه كلها سنه شيعه
سيد فؤاد ضيفنا ضيفنا من يريفان كان يتحدث
عما عاناه الارمن
عذرا ضيفنا من يريفاني يتحدث عما عاناه
الارمن من من معامله يرى بانها سيئه
تجاههم وبالتالي هذا ما دفعهم الى الخروج
لو كانوا بطريقه لو عملوا بطريقه مختلفه
لبقوا في في الاقليم
اولا
المساعدات دوليه والان وكل شيء كل شيء في
الشوارع وفي
تحت اشراف المجتمع الدولي وهناك اشرطه
فيديو
يوميا هذا الباذنجان لم تقطع حتى الانترنت
عن تلك المنطقه وذلك لكي يستطيع هؤلاء
الناس
ان
يستخدموا او يصل الى المجتمع الدولي فلو
كان هناك اي مشكله فكانت كانوا كتابه عنها
شكرا لك وانها نعم اتضحت فكرتك سيد فؤاد
شيراكوف من باكو شكرا جزيلا لك نائب مدير
مركز دراسات جنوب القوقاز وشكرا للدكتوره
الكسندر ماركا روف مدير الفرع الارماني
لمعه رابطه الدول المستقله كان معنا من
يريدا
[موسيقى]
الى تداعيات حدث حريق الحمدانيه في العراق
حيث اقيمت مراسم وعزاء جماعيه لاهالي
الضحايا وصدعوات لمحاسبه المسؤولين عن
الحادثه كان المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه
العراقيه قد قال ان عدد قتل الحريق بلغ
ثمانيه وتسعين بينما تجاوز عدد الجرحى 100
شخص
[موسيقى]
في الكنيسه جمعهم المصاب يواسي كل منهم
الاخر
في اول قداس يقام بعد حريق قاعه الاعراس
في الحمدانيه ابتهل اهالي الضحايا طالبين
الرحمه لموتاهم سائلين لهم الراحه الابديه
لكن صلاح لم يستطع حضور القداس كان مشغولا
بدفن زوجه اخيه بعد يوم واحد من دفن ابنه
قضوا جميعا في الحريق الحزن على من فقد
يثقل كاهله لكن الاثقل على نفسه انه لا
يعرف شيئا عن مصير زوجته واخ له وزوجته
يقول انهم حضروا زفاف جميعا ثم اختفوا بعد
الحادث يعني معقول البشر ممنوع
يعني ما اتوقع
جمجمه تبقى عظام تبقى اسنان تبقى يعني ما
شفنا كل شي
التعرف على هويات الضحايا امر يؤرق
السلطات المحليه في نينوى فعدد الضحايا
كبير والكادر البشري محدود لهذا ارسلت
بغداد فريقا متخصصا في التعرف على الهويات
لعل امتار صلاح يقطعون الشك باليقين
ويزيدوا تضارب الارقام الرسميه بشان عدد
القتلى والجرحى من حاله الغموض لدى اسر
الضحايا ولهذا الامر اسباب يرى الهلال
الاحمر انها وجيهه حقيقه لا توجد هنالك
احصائيه ثابته الى حد الان لانه هنالك
يعني اعداد متفاوته بسبب نقل الاشخاص الى
المستشفيات مختلفه في منطقه اربيل ودهوك
والموصل لا توجد احصائيه ثابته
مقاطع فيديو خرجت الى العالم بعد يومين من
الماساه وثقت اللحظات الاولى للحادث
انتشرت النيران بسرعه كبيره فاجات
الحاضرين فتدافعوا نحو الخارج لكن بعد
فوات الاواني بالنسبه لكثيرين
تحول هذا الجدار الى لوحه تذكاريه تؤرخ
لضحايا الحريق وسيمر وقت طويل قبل ان
تستجمع هذه البلده الصغيره شتات نفسها
فالفقد كبير والوجع اكبر وغايه منى سكانها
الان محاسبه المسؤولين عن الفاجعه
الحمدانيه محافظه نينوى
واخذ امر رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني
امر
بمتابعه التحقيقات ومواصله تفتيش المباني
العامه وقاعات المناسبات والمطاعم
والفنادق وفحص شروط السلام العامه
والاحتياطات هو اجراءات الوقايه من
الحرائق والحوادث المحتمله واشدد السوداني
خلال زيارته للمصابين على ضروره انزال
اقصى العقوبات بمن وصفهم بالمقصرين
والمهملين
والمتسببين في الحريق مؤكدا انه لا تسامح
مع اي تقصير من اي موظف حكومي
معنا من بغداد الدكتور حسين علاوي مستشار
رئيس الوزراء العراقي
سيد علاوي يعني الان ما هي الاليه ما هي
الترتيبات ما هي الخطه
الموضوع من قبل الحكومه لمواجهه
يعني تداعيات ما حصل وماذا عن التحقيقات
حتى الان
يعني مساء الخير عليك مساء الخير على
المشاهدين الكرام التحقيقات تجري على قدم
وثاق وهنالك طبعا في الساعه الاولى تم
اعتقال المجموعه الاساسيه التي كانت تشرف
على اداره واستثمار هذا المرفا السياحي
القاعه وكذلك بالمقابل البحث عن الضحايا
بعمليه حصرهم وجردهم من اجل تقديم تعويضات
سريعه وعاجله وكذلك هنالك عمليه ابتعاث
لبعض الحالات الحرجه الى تركيا وجرى اليوم
الدفعه الاولى وقد يجري دفعه تحضير الى
دفعه ثانيه وقد يكون هنالك دفعات اخرى
وكذلك بالمقابل هنالك جرد الى قدرات
المباني الممنوحه للقطاع الخاص والمشغلين
الى هذه المرافق السياحيه من اجل لا تتكرر
هذه الحاله بالاضافه طبعا الى ان
التحقيقات الجنائيه وكذلك بالمقابل الخاصه
بالدفاع المدني والادله الجنائيه قد وصلت
الى مراحل المتقدمه جدا وقد يقدم التقرير
بصوره نهائيه للسيد رئيس الوزراء وطبعا
السيد رئيس وزراء استاذ محمد السوداني في
زياره اليوم الى الحمدانيه كان واضحا جدا
اشاره الى ان الفساد هو من ولد هذه
المشكله وسوء الاداره وسوء المتابعه وكذلك
بالمقابل
السابق على مدى العشرين سنه الذي قيل
اليوم لكن ما رايك بما قيل اليوم ان اكثر
من 30% من المباني الحكوميه مباني حكوميه
نتحدث مبنيه بهذه الطريقه بنفس هذه المواد
سريعه الاشتعال وهناك ايضا اجزاء من منازل
وبيوت وابنيه ايضا تبنى بهذه الطريقه
والحكومه تعلم بها والاجهزه كلها تعلم بها
ما الذي فوجئتم به الان
لا هو لم نفاجئ حقيقه هنالك عمل من قبل
مديريه الدفاع المدني في وزاره الداخليه
وهنالك احصاء لسبعه الاف بنايه 4000 منها
قد تم تقريمها وفقا للقانون النافذ الذي
لا يعطي عقوبات صارمه او يلزم صاحب
البنايه بعقوبات يعني ماديه وجنائيه
وغرامات ماليه حتى يلتزم اكثر بهذا
الموضوع نعم نقول لك ان كلامك دقيق ولكن
بالمقابل فيما يخص الان المعالجه لهذا
الارض الحكومه العراقيه تعمل سوى بمنع هذه
المواد البناء السريعه الاشتعال او كذلك
الزام من يمتلك المرافع السياحيه بنصب
منظومات مكافحه الحريق وكذلك بالمقابل
مكافحه التغيير المناخي الذي يعد العراق
الخامس عالميا بهذا التاثير وكذلك
بالمقابل مواجهه الارث السابق لعمليه عدم
احصاء هذه المباني ومراجعته باختصار يعني
عندما شاهدت التقرير
قلت انني ساسالك عن الموضوع حتى لو لم تكن
انت المتخصص فيه يعني هل يعقل ان اشخاص
الان لا يعرف اين هم لم يتم تحديد امكانه
قتلوا في هذا الحريق ولهم معروفون اين لا
في المستشفيات وغير ذلك وهذا عدد لا باس
به يعني
ظهر حتى الان كيف يتم الرد على هذا
الموضوع
لا اكيد الكوادر الصحيه والكوادر الدفاع
المدني قد عملت منذ الساعات الاولى على
عمليه جرد واحصاء وهذا كانت اوامر واضحه
من السيد رئيس وزراء
بالساعات الاولى لسبع نقاط الاساسيه التي
كان منها اراد ان يكون هنالك جرد واحصاء
وهنالك مستشار رئيس وزراء موجود في مقر
الحادث حقيقه يحصي هذا الموضوع ويتابع مع
السيد وزير الصحه والسيد وزير الداخليه
والسيده وزيره الهجره والمؤجرين ومحافظ
نينوى وبالتالي هنالك متابعه لهذه الحاله
لكن قد تكون هنالك تحت الانقاذ الخاص
بالبناء بعد ان تم فتح عدد من الممرات
الخاصه باجلاء المواطنين بواسطه عجلات
ثقيله قد يكون هنالك تحت هذا الركام والان
يجري لان ظهرت فيديوهات
ظهر بها مواطنون يتابعون حالاتهم في
الايام الاولى حقيقه للحادث والساعات
الاولى وبالتالي يجري الان عمليه المراجعه
لكل جثامين الضحايا وكذلك بالمقابل الجرح
الذي نتمنى لهم الشفاء العاجل دكتور حسين
ع لاوي مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي من
بغداد شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط مسيره
اوكرانيه في اجواء منطقه بيلجورود غربيه
البلاد من جهته قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
دفاعاته الجويه اعترضت فجر اليوم 34 طائره
مسيره من نوع شاهد من اصل اربع واربعين
اطلقها الروس باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
واضاف ان قواته خاضت اكثر من عشرين
اشتباكا مع القوات الروسيه على مختلف
جبهات القتال في الساعات القليله الماضيه
وقال الجيش الاوكراني انه احرز تقدما
جديدا في محور باتجاه بلدتي اودراديفيكا
وشوميوف واضاف ان قوته نجحت في التقدم
ايضا في اتجاه بلده كليشيفكا بعد ان
استعاد السيطره عليها الاسبوع الماضي
واشار الجيش الاوكراني الى انه بات يسيطر
ناريا على جزء من الشارع الرئيس السريع
الرابط بين بلده غورليفكا التي كانت خطيئه
لسيطره الموالين لروسيا ومدينه بخمس
في هذه الاثناء اعلن الناطق باسم الرئاسه
الروسيه
زياده الانفاق الدفاعي وقال ان ذلك امر
ضروري للغايه لان البلاد تعيش ما سماها
حاله حرب هجينه
وقعت اسرائيل على صفقه مع المانيا لبيعها
منظومه صواريخ المضاده للصواريخ ارواحيتس
ثلاثه وتعتبر هذه الصفقه الاكبر من نوعيه
في تاريخ الجيش الاسرائيلي بقيمه تقدر
باربعه مليارات يورو وتتضمن منظومات
للرادار واداره عمليات الاطلاق والاعتراض
على ان يتم تسليمها لبرلين خلال العامين
المقبلين
وقال وزير الدفاع الالماني بوريس
بيستوريوس ان توقيع على الاتفاقيه هو
مساهمه اسرائيليه في امن وصمود المانيا
مضيفا ان الصفقه ستعزز العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين برلين وتل ابيب
السياسه الامنيه والدفاعيه والتعاون بين
المانيا واسرائيل وخصوصا في هذا المشروع
الكبير تظهر بوضوح مستوى غير عادي من
الثقه والصداقه المتبادله العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين الجانبين ستتعزز بشكل
اكبر من خلال نظام اورو ثلاثه وهو مساهمه
اسرائيليه في امننا وصمود المانيا لذلك
انا سعيد للغايه وهو يوم جميل لالمانيا
واسرائيل بين البلدين
من جانب قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
واثقلان ان الاتفاقيه هي الاكبر في مجال
الصناعات الدفاعيه الاسرائيليه واصفا
اياها بالتاريخيه
بتوقيعنا البسيط اليوم نحن الاثنين نكون
قد صنعنا التاريخ هذه اللحظه من التاريخ
ترتكز على احداث ماضينا وتحدد مصيرنا في
المستقبل نظام ارو ثلاثه لالمانيا هو اكبر
صفقه يتم توقيعها هذا اليوم نحن ملتزمون
بالتسليم الفعلي وفي الوقت المناسب هذا
الاتفاق دليل ملموس على ان اسرائيل
والمانيا وصلتها الى مستوى من العلاقات
اصبحت فيه تتبادلان المعلومات الاستخباريه
والحساسه والمعرفه والقدرات العسكريه منذ
تاسيس دولتنا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت شركه الخدمات العامه الحكوميه في
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس ان فراقها الفنيه
في درنه تواصل فتح الطرق والمسارات
بالمناطق والاحياء التي اجتاحتها
الفيضانات وذكرت الشركه ان هذه الفرق تعمل
على تكثيف اعمال التعقيم
لمكافحه القوارض داخل شوارع المدينه
المتضرره خوفا من انتشار الاوبئه والامراض
وقد اعلنا مركز طب الطوارئ والدعم في
ليبيا انتشار اثنتين وثلاثين من جثث ضحايا
الفيضانات في مدينه درنه امس الاربعاء
وافاد المركز ان فراقه الطبيه قدمت رعايه
طبيه لاكثر من 470 متضررا من السيول في
مدن ومناطق الجبل الاخضر شرقي البلاد
معنى من مدينه البيضاء شرق ليبيا عثمان
البلبيسي المدير الاقليمي للشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا في المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
التابعه للامم المتحده سيد البلبيسي مرحبا
بك
لنبدا اولا بمستوى الاستجابه الانسانيه
بالنظر الى حجم هذه الكارثه التي ضربت شرق
ليبيا وتحديدا مدينه درنه
بدايه طبعا حجم الكارثه هو كبير
والنتائج اظهرت انها حجم الدمار بالاضافه
الى حجم عدد المفقودين والوفيات
قد فاق اي توقعات
وتقوم فرق عمل الامم المتحده بالاضافه الى
فرق الانقاذ من مختلف دول العالم وايضا
الحكومه الليبيه بتقديم المساعدات ولكن
نظرا لحجم الكارثه هناك المزيد
ما زال يجب تقديمه للاستجابه لهذه الحاله
الانسانيه الطارئه ما هو المطلوب يعني
المزيد في في اي مجال تحديدا
في الوقت الحالي تم تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه ولكن الان اهم الاحتياجات هي
ضمان استمرار تقديم المساعدات الغذائيه
والمساعدات الصحيه
بالاضافه الى
تقييم الاضرار العمل على فتح الطرق حيث تم
تدمير الكثير من الجسور والعمل جاري على
ايجاد طرق بديله ولكن مع اقتراب موسم
الشتاء يجب العمل على فتح الطرق الرئيسيه
وايجاد طرق لوصل اجزاء المدينه ببعضها
ايضا التقارير افادت بان هناك مساحات
كبيره من الاراضي الزراعيه تم تدميرها
وبالتالي هذا سيؤثر على المدى الطويل على
مصادر الرزق والاكتفاء الذاتي للمدن اللي
درنا والمدن المحيطه
في من خلال زيارتنا الى عدد من المستشفيات
ايضا وجدنا هناك نقص في كثير من التخصصات
ومنها امراض العظام الامراض وامراض
الاسنان
ايضا بالنسبه
لزيارتكم
واطلاعكم على
على عمليات البحث عن الجثث والضحايا وايضا
عمليات الاغاثه من بين الضحايا كما هو
معروف هناك
مهاجرون غير نظاميين وقعوا ضحيه هذه
الكارثه هل
جرى بحث ملثهم بشكل منفصل هل جرى التعرف
عليهم ماذا بالنسبه الى الى اوضاعهم او
اوضاع ذويهم
نعم طبعا هناك تواصل بشكل مستمر مع
السفارات الدول المعنيه
وحسب تقديرات المنظمه هناك ما يزيد عن 450
وفاه من بين المهاجرين الموجودين في مدينه
درنه وهذا الرقم قابل للزياده
فاليوم التقينا مع مجموعه من الجاليه
السودانيه الذين افادوا ان هناك ما يقارب
223 شخص قد تم دفنهم فعلا ولكن طبعا نعمل
الان على تاكيد هذه الارقام لاصدار تقارير
مفصله بهذا الموضوع عدد الوفيات يزيد عن
450 وعدد المفقودين حتى الان يزيد عن 500
شخص هل يعني هل بالامكان التعرف عليهم على
جثثهم
في الوقت الحالي نعم تم التعرف على كثير
من الجثث وتمت عمليه الدفن لكثير منهم
تحمل المسؤوليه كامله طيب
تحدث عن الزياره اود ان اسال
عن نتائج هذه الزياره هل كانت مجرد زياره
استطلاعيه
هذه الزياره كانت لي الاطلاع على عمل فرق
الامم المتحده وفريق عمل المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره على الارض وايضا تقييم الاحتياجات
في الفتره الحاليه لما يمكن او ما يجب
تقديمه في المستقبل القريب واستمعنا الى
اراء الخبراء والاشخاص المتضررين هناك
احتياجات في عديد من الميادين منها
وبالاخص مجال الدعم النفسي والدعم النفسي
الاجتماعي حيث وخاصه لمقدمه الخدمه في
الخطوط الاولى
مقدمين العمل الصحي والاستجابات الانسانيه
بالاضافه الى سكان المدينه فكما نعلم
مدينه درنه مرت بعديد من الازمات لم
تتعافى من الازمات الامنيه حتى جاءتها هذه
الكارثه والتي تحتاج الى وقت فما زال
الناس تحت وقع الصدمه ولكن في الايام
والاسابيع القادمه سنبدا في حصر الاضرار
والاستفاقه من الصدمه والتفكير فيما يجب
عمله تاليا من الملفت للنظر ايضا اننا
قابلنا عدد من الاشخاص مما فقدوا ذويهم
وعائلاتهم ولكن ما زالوا مستمرين بتقديم
العمل الانساني للناجين وهذا شيء ملفت
طبعا وغير غريب على الشعب الليبي من مدينه
البيضاء شرق ليبيا عثمان البلبيسي المدير
الاقليمي للشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا في
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم
المتحده شكرا جزيلا لك
حضر الرئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن اعتبره
تهديدا جديدا للديمقراطيه الامريكيه مضيفا
انه تهديد يتعرض له الدستور والمؤسسات
الامريكيه واضاف بايدن في خطاب له بولايه
اريزونا ان هناك حركه متطرفه لا تشارك
الامريكيين معتقداتهم الاساسيه وتتالف من
متشددين من الحزب الجمهوري كما اتهم في
الوقت ذاته الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بمحاوله تقويد الدستور والمؤسسات الحكوميه
الامريكيه وبانه يعتقد انه فوق القانون
حسب قوله
وقد عقدت لجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي اولى جلساتها المتعلقه بالمزاعم
بشان علاقه الرئيس جو بايدن بالانشطه
الماليه لنجله هنتر في مسعن يهدف الى
محاكمته برلمانيا ويتهم شارعون جمهوريون
بايدن باساءه استخدام منصبه حين كان نائبا
للرئيس بهدف تحقيق مكاسب ماليه لعائلته
وكان نواب جمهوريون قد اصدروا مذكره قالوا
فيها انهم حصلوا على الاف الوثائق
المتعلقه بالقضيه وانهم يسعون للوصول الى
سجلات اضافيه بينما يرى النواب
الديمقراطيون ان الجمهوريين لم يعثروا على
دليل يربط الرئيس بالمعاملات الماليه
لنجله ويقولون ان التحقيقات تاتي ردا على
المحاكمات البرلمانيه التي استهدفت الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب خلال فتره ولايته
اقر برلمان وكوريا الشماليه قانونا يكرس
في الدستور وضع البلاد كقوه نوويه وفي
كلمه امام البرلمان قال زعيم كوريا
الشماليه
ان سياسه بناء القوه النوويه صارت دائمه
باعتبارها القانون الاساسي للدوله الان
واضاف انه من المهم للغايه تسريع تحديث
الاسلحه النوويه للحفاظ على ميزه الردع
الاستراتيجي في وجه ما وصفها بالاستفزازات
الامريكيه في المنطقه
وقدمت كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
واليابان التعديل الذي اجرته كوريا
الشماليه على سياستها لتكريس القوه
النوويه وقال بيان صادر عن وزاره الخارجيه
الكوريه الجنوبيه ان المفوضين النوويين
لسولوا واشنطن وتوكيو عقدوا اجتماعا
هاتفيا لمناقشه التهديدات النوويه
المتزايده من جانب
قتل ثلاثه اشخاص في اطلاق نار استهدف
مركزا طبيا تابعا لاحدى الجامعات في مدينه
روتردام الهولنديه ومنزلا مهجورا
وقلق ايد الشرطه
روتردام انه تم توقيف مسلح الذي عمد الى
اطلاق النار بصفه عشوائيه في الموقعين
واضاف ان الشخص معروف لدى القضاء وادين
قبل عامين بالعنف ضد الحيوانات مشيرا الى
ان دوافعه لم تعرف بعد وانه سيمثل امام
قيد التحقيق مطلع الاسبوع المقبل
في مواجهه التزايد ظاهره الاستخدام
المجاني للانتاج الموسيقي طلبت لجنه في
البرلمان البريطاني الحكومه بالتراجع عن
الاعفاءات التي منحتها لمطوري الذكاء
الاصطناعي ودعت الى حمايه حقوق الملكيه
الفكريه للموزعين الاصليين واصدار
التشريعات ووضع ضوابط لاستخدام هذه
التقنيه التي باتت تنافس الابداع الفني
جيتار للزينه في منزل ايديتيا فانتاجه
الموسيقي لا يحتاج الى اكثر من جهاز حاسوب
فوي هو موقعه الالكتروني الذي يستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي لتركيب اي صوت على اي
موسيقى وباي لغه
هذه الديانه حداد تغني لعمرو دياب مثلا
[موسيقى]
شعبيه كبيره ولكن ليس في اوساط الفنانين
نعمل حاليا على ضمان ارضاء كل الاطراف وان
يحصل الجميع على حصصهم العادله انه امر
يقلقنا وعلينا ان نعالجه نريد نموذجا
يستفيد منه المنتجون الاصليون والمطورون
وهذا ما نتفاوض عليه الان
هذا دنمارك ستريت لندن تاريخ الموسيقى
البريطانيه حاضر في محل ناشرين الموسيقيين
واستوديوهات التسجيل يقول رواده ان
الموسيقى التقليديه روحا تغيب في التقنيات
الحديثه
الناس يميزون ويعرفون الفرق بين شخص ابدع
موسيقاه ووضع شغفه فيها واخر انشاها بشكل
اصطناعي لكن علينا ان ننتظر الى اي مدى
سيتطور ذلك
لا يخفي صناع الموسيقى في بريطانيا توجسهم
من تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي يرون فيها
سطوا على حقوق الملكيه الفكريه
وانتقاسا من قيمه الابداع البشري لذلك لا
غرابه ان تتعالى الاصوات للمطالبه بوضع
ضوابط لحمايه المبدعين من سطوه
التكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]
فقد طالبت لجنه مختصه من النواب الحكومه
البريطانيه بمنع مطوري الذكاء الاصطناعي
من الاستخدام المجاني للموسيقى والاعمال
الفنيه
قلقنا الاكبر هو ان البعض يستخدم العمل
الموسيقي الابداعيه دون اذن ما يعني انهم
سيحصلون على العائدات منا وهذا يمثل مشكله
كبيره لنا اذا لم يدفع الناس للفنانين
مقابل اعمالهم
الحكومه قالت انها ستتخذ نهجا متزنا
وعقلانيا للتعامل مع القضيه لكن التطور
متسارع وسيتجاوز حيز الموسيقى الى الاداب
والفنون رحله حتميه للجميع نحو مستقبل لم
يعد الذكاء فيه بشريا فحسب محمد المدهون
الجزيره لندن
جوله الحصاد متواصله معكم مشاهدينا على
راس السعاده
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في جوله الحصاد وفي
العناوين
البرهان يكلف اعضاء في مجلس السياده
بالاشراف على الوزارات والهيئات الحكوميه
واشنطن تفرض عقوبات على وزير سابق
للخارجيه وشركتين مرتبطتين بقوات الدعم
السريع وتتهمهم بتفويض الامن وعرقله
الانتقال الديمقراطي في السودان
تزامنا مع لجوء اكثر من نصف سكان اقليم
كاراباخ الى ارمينيا سلطات ارمن الاقليم
تعلن حل نفسها
يصف الوضع بالتطهير العرقي واذربيجان
تتهمه بعرقله الادماج وتؤكد التزامها
بمجتمع متعدد الاثنيات
استمرار اجواء الحداد في العراق وعزاء
جماعي في ضحايا حريق الحمدانيه
السلطات ترجع سبب الحادث للتقصير والاهمال
وتتوعد بمحاسبه المسؤولين
[موسيقى]
في احداث تطورات السودان فرضت الولايات
المتحده عقوبات على وزير الخارجيه
السوداني السابق في عهد البشير علي كرتي
وشركتين احداهما مقرها روسيا بتهمه مفاقمه
عدم الاستقرار في البلاد
وخلال سعه الاخيره تبادل الجيش السوداني
وقوات دعم السريع القصف المدفعيه في
العاصمه الخرطوم وشهدت مناطق من المدينه
مواجهات بين الطرفين سياسيا اعلن رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان تكليف
اعضاء من المجلس بالاشراف على الوزارات
الحكوميه في البلاد
وتضمنت قائمه المكلفين شخصيات معروفه في
المجلس
معاركم مستعره في الخرطوم وضواحيها وقررت
مهمه للبرهان من بورتسودان ما لا يتغير في
العاصمه السودانيه منذ خمسه اشهر هو عزيز
الرصاص ودخان القصي بين الاخوه الاعداء
سمع دوي في جره متتاليه خلال الساعات
الاخيره في مركز المدينه وتحدثت مصادر عن
تحليق كثيف لطائره الجيش شرقي المدينه
ذكرت ان قوات الدعم السريع قصفت بالمدفعيه
مواقع الجيش عند نقطه جبل اولياء جنوبي
الخرطوم لم تسلم مدينه ام درمان من
مواجهات بين الطرفين المتحاربين في بلد
ينزف بسبب هذا الصراع وما قبله من ازمات
كبيره وكثيره تكلفه جديده لاسماء معروفه
اعلنها رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان يتضمن القرار اشراف اعضاء مجلس
السياده على شؤون الوزارات الحكوميه في
البلاد وقد كلف البرهان نائبه مالك
بالاشراف على عدد من الوزارات من بينها
الطاقه والنفط والتربيه والتعليم والثقافه
والاعلام والتنميه الاجتماعيه والصحه
والتعليم العالي بينما اسندت الى عضو مجلس
السياده شمس الدين كباشي مهام الاشراف على
وزاره الداخليه والخارجيه والعدل والري
والموارد المائيه ورئاسه مجلس الوزراء
بموجب القرار سيتولى ياسر العطاء شؤون
وزاره الدفاع والماليه وبنك السودان
المركزي بينما سيشرف عضو المجلس السيادي
ابراهيم جابر على وزاره الزراعه والثروه
الحيوانيه والتجاره والصناعه والاستثمار
والتعاون الدولي والاتصالات والنقل يطرح
القرار تساؤلات عن اليه اداره تلك
الوزارات والمؤسسات بعيدا عن الخرطوم
عاصمه البلد الغارق في الفوضى والتناحر
سيف العقوبه الامريكيه لم يغب عن تطورات
المشهد السوداني الكثير التعقيدات هذه
الشهور
وزاره الخزانه انها استهدفت علي كارتي
وزير الخارجيه السابق الذي اصبح زعيما
للحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه بعد الاطاحه
بالبشير عام 2019 كما فرضت العقوبات ايضا
على
وهي شركه مقرها السودان تتهمها واشنطن
بانها تستخدم وسيله مشتريات لقوات الدعم
السريع استنادا لبيان الخزانه فهذه الشركه
كانت تنسق مع شركه الامدادات العسكريه
ايفيا تريد ومقرها روسيا والتي استهدفتها
هذه العقوبات الازمه الانسانيه بكل
تفاصيلها المروعه والمرعبه تزيد مع كل يوم
اخر السودان محروم فيه من الاستقرار
الامني والسياسي اكثر من سته ملايين
سوداني على بعد خطوه واحده من المجاعه
تستغيث الامم المتحده تفشي الكوليرا وحم
الضنك يزيد المشهد المزرقه تامه مع بدء
الامطار الموسميه وانهيار القطاع الصحي
بسبب الصراع الاكثر تضررا ولايات الكظارف
والبحر الاحمر وشمال كردفان والخرطوم
تتعدد اسباب الاوبئه ومنها تلوث مياه
الشرب من جثث غير مدفونه ومن النفايات من
كل النواحي وعلى مد الجغرافيا الشاسعه
السودان ليس بخير وشعبه تضيق به سبل
الحياه شبه الطبيعيه
معنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور اسامه
عيدروس الكاتب السوداني او الاكاديميه
السودانيه المختص بشؤون السياسيه
والعسكريه دكتور اسامه مرحبا بك
خلفيات هذا القرار الذي اتخذه البرهان
بتكليف اعضاء من المجلس
السيادي بالاشراف على الوزارات ومن
بورسودان
وفي الحقيقه منذ الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر يعني حينما يعني قام البرهان
بالانقلاب وخرج على الحريه والتغيير او
اخرجهم من السلطه واستمر لعامين كاملين لم
يكن هنالك سلطه تنفيذيه بالمعنى المتعارف
عليه وكلف بعض الاشخاص باداره الوزارات
وليس هنالك رئيس وزراء بعد استقاله عبد
الله حمدوك في يناير
بعدها طوال هذه الفتره غابت السلطه
التنفيذيه الى حد ما منذ بدايه الحرب غابه
الاداره المدنيه للحرب المجتمع السوداني
مجتمع ريزليانس مجتمع مقاوم
يساعد نفسه بنفسه يمتص الكثير
منذ خروج من القياده العامه يعني الى تلك
اللحظه يعني ربما كان قرار تعيين مالك
عقار بعد اقاله حميدتي من منصبه يعني
محاوله لايجاد
اداره مدنيه للحرب او اعاده السلطه
التنفيذيه الى مدى لكن تسارعت الخطوات
بشكل اكبر بعد خروج البرهان من القياده
العامه ووصوله الى بورسودان وقيامه بجولات
خارجيه وبدا شكل من اشكال الاداره المدنيه
للحرب يظهر هذا جزء منه لكنها خطوه بسيطه
جدا
نعم لكن السياق او الاخراج
عن طريق تسريبات او تسريب خطاب مسجل له
بهذا المعنى
هي هي كل شيء الان يعني مع هذه الحرب
مضطرب في السودان يعني كل شيء مضطرب
ويحتاج الناس الى وقفه يعني كما يحتاج هو
الان البرهان سلطه الامر الواقع في
السودان
ويحتاج الى ان ينظر الى الحكومه التنفيذيه
برؤيه اكثر عمقا مثل رؤيته لاداره الحرب
نفسها والعمليات العسكريه يعني بانه لم
بان السلطه في الخرطوم لم تعد
باكثرياتها للجيش وللبرهان هل هذا معناه
ذلك الخرطوم بها سلطه يعني محافظ محافظه
كرري هذه واحده من المحافظات الامنه تماما
بقيه المناطق في الخرطوم هي اما مناطق
للسلب والنهب يقوم فيها اللصوص
بنهب بيوت المواطنين وتهجلهم او اما مناطق
عمليات عسكريه ففعليا لا يمكن لسلطه ان
تكون خارجه عن سلطه اي طرف على الاقل طيب
ماذا ماذا لو
ردت دعم السريع بتشكيل الحكومه مدنيه في
الخرطوم وهذا الامر كان المح اليه حماتي
هو لا يسيطر على الخرطوم هو منتشر في بيوت
المواطنين في الخرطوم وفي المرافق العامه
وهو في وضع الدفاع ينتظر الجيش في هجومه
هو ليس له رفاهيه ان يتحدث بالاضافه الى
ذلك يعني هذه العمليات اذا نظرت لها فعلها
فعلا اذا نظرت لها نظره لو شكل واعلن
تشكيل الحكومه مدنيه وما المانع هو سيشكل
حكومه مدنيه هو الان يريد ان يستلم السلطه
في السودان هو تمرد على الجيش تمرد على
الدوله
قام حربا ارتكب جرائم في السودان يمكن ان
يفعل كل شيء لكن في النهايه ستقف هذه
الحرب ويرجع الناس الى سلطه القانون حينما
يرجع الناس الى سلطه القانون عليهم ان
يعني
يحترموا قرا
رات القانون
ويعاقبوا بما قاموا به خلال
الاكاديمي السوداني المختص بشؤون السياسيه
والعسكريه شكرا
معنى من واشنطن
سفيرشن مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق لشؤون افريقيا السيد ديفيد شان
مرحبا بك هل لهذه القرارات الامريكيه فرض
العقوبات على شخصيات وشركات سودانيه هل
ترى واشنطن ان لها اثرا فعليا على ارض
الواقع
من المهم ان نفهم
طبيعه العقوبات الامريكيه ضد السودان
الولايات المتحده
تدرك فرط مثل هذه العقوبات قبل بضعه الشرب
بقطع كل المساعدات الامريكيه للسداد عدا
فيما يتعلق مساعدات الانسانيه التي استمرت
وايضا تشجع البنك الدولي وصندوق النقد
الدولي على
انهاء عاده التفاوض حول الديون السودانيه
هذه كانت العقوبات مهمه وقد يكون لها
تاثير بصرف النظر عما يحصل في السودان اما
العقوبات فيها حصلت مؤخرا فتاثيراتها اقل
فهي عقوبات
ضد عدد صغير من الشركات فرديه واخرها
امس
الشركه المقرها في روسيا واخرى مقرها في
السودان وواحد والشخص واحد في السودان
هاتان الشركتان ليس لديهم قوه او ارتباطات
الماليه كبيره مع الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي الولايات المتحده ليس لديها
تاثير عليها وبالتالي فهتان الشركتان ليس
لهم اي تعاملات الماليه مع الولايات
المتحده وبالتالي الجواب هو ان هذه القوات
الاخيره لن يكون لها التاثيرات كبيره
لكنها تبعث برساله سياسيه بان الولايات
المتحده تعارضي حد كبير الحرب الجاريه
حاليا في السودان ولكن الا تبعث برساله
سياسيه مقابله تقول ان هذا اقصى ما يمكن
ان تفعله الولايات المتحده او تؤثر في
الازمه السودانيه
نعم نعم فعلا تبعث برساله سياسيه هناك
بالتاكيد حدود لما يمكن ان تقوم به في هذا
الوضع
فقط وقد تفوق التجاوز هذه الحدود وقد تكون
هناك بعض الشركات الاضافيه او الافراد
الاضافيين الذين اما يدعمون قوات الدعم
السريع او قوات المسلحه السودانيه ايضا
سيتعرضون للعقوبات في الاسابيع والاشهر
التاليه القادمه
قليل على الوضع ولكن ذلك لن يغير الوقائع
على الارض في الواقع هناك نفوذ اكبر من
بعض الدول العربيه وخاصه دول
الخليج حول ما يحصل حاليا في السودان مما
كان ان تقوم به الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده ليس لديها نفوذ او انها
لا تريد ان يكون لديها نفوذ في الوقت
الحاضر لان السودان ليس من اولوياتها
لا اعتقد ان هذا صحيح تماما فاعتقد
الولايات المتحده
تمارس قدرا كبيرا من ضغط او نفوذ لديها
لكن المشكله هي ان هذا النفوذ او التاثير
محدود والولايات المتحده غير مستعده لقطع
المساعدات الانسانيه عن الشعب السوداني
الذي يحتاجها لمساعدات بشكل كبير نتيجه
الحرب الجاريه بين قوات المسلحه السودانيه
قوات الدعم السريع وبالتالي
هذا ليس
المجال المعقول لفرض المزيد من العقوبات
اما بعد ذلك فسنا كمجال اخر
للعقوبات فالامر لا يتعلق بعدم الرغبه على
المذله المزيد بل الامر يتعلق ما لديك من
وسائل الضغط او نفوذ اذا كان
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون افريقيا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
بعد ثلاثه عقود
يسدل ارمن كهرباء الستاره على جمهوريتهم
المعلنه من طرف واحد فقد وقع زعيم ارمن
الاقليم مرسوما بحل السلطات الاقليم
ومؤسساته مع بدايه العام المقبل ودع زعيم
ارمن كراباخ سكان الاقليم الموجودين داخله
او خارج الى التعرف على شروط الاندماج
داخل دوله اذربيجان
انتهى حلم ارمني اقليمي كرباخ باستمرار ما
سموه جمهوريه
زعيم الارمن في اقليم كرباخ اصدر مرسوما
بحل السلطات والمؤسسات فيه بدءا من مطلع
2024 وطبعا تسليم السلاح بهذا تطوى صفحه
بقعه جغرافيه لطالما كانت بركانا خامدا
يثور كل حين مشعلا معه الصراع بين ارمينيا
و اذربيجان
اذا عادت الارض لدربيجان ويتجه قسم كبير
من سكانها الارمن نحو ارمينيا ودافعهم
مخاوف تراكمه عبر عقود من نزاع مسلح
بدات قصه اقليم كاراباخ البالغه مساحته
قرابه 4000
كيلومترا مربع عقب انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي عام 91 واستقلال كل من ارمينيا
واذربيجان بادرت ارمينيا بالهجوم وضم
اقليم كارباخ الى سلطتها مع سبع مناطق
اذربيجانيه اخرى عام 92 اعلن ارمن اقليم
كاراباخ استقلاله واقامه ما سمي جمهوريه
ارتساخ وعاصمتها استيفانا لم يعترف بها
احد حتى ارمينيا نفسها
عام 93 اصدر مجلس الامن قرارا ادان احتلال
ارمينيا لاقليم كارباخ واكد انه جزء من
اراضي اذربيجان مع ذلك لم تتوقف الحرب حتى
عام 94 بتوقيع الطرفين اتفاقا لوقف اطلاق
النار ظل الاقليم بعدها بسنوات يعيش حاله
حرب ولا سل اشتباكات وقصف متبادل او معارك
قصيره الامد حتى حسم الجيش الاذربيجاني
هذه القضيه العالقه بسيطرته على الاقليم
واعادته لضرب جان انتهت حسابات الجغرافيا
والتاريخ والسلطه لاقليم كراباخ لصالح
اذربيجان اما ارمينيا فتشير تصريحات
مسؤوليها ان احداث اقليم كرباخ الاخيره
ستكون نقطه بدايه لاعاده النظر في حسابات
السياسه والتحالفات
ومع استمرار موجه النزوح من اقليم كاراباخ
قال رئيس الوزراء الارميني نيكول باشنيان
انه لن يبقى اي ارمني في الاقليم في غضون
ايام واعتبر باشنيان في تصريحات اورادتها
وكاله انترفاكس الروسيه انما يجري في
اقليم كاراباخ تطهير عرقي وتهجير مضيفا ان
ذلك ما كانت بلاده تحذر العالم منه
في المقابل دانه الخارجيه لا اذربيجانيه
بشده ما وصفتها بمحاوله ارمينيا تضليل
المجتمع الدولي كما دانت الوزاره تصريحات
باشنيان واعتبرت في بيان ان باشنيان يعطل
جهود اذربيجان في المساعده الانسانيه
وعمليه اعاده الادماج وادعت الخارجيه
لذربيجانيه السكان الارمن الى عدم مغادره
منازلهم متعهده للحفاظ على مجتمع اذربيجان
متعدد الاثنيات على حد تعبيرها
معنى من العاصمه الجورجيه تبليس
الكاتبه الصحفيه المختصه في شؤون القوقاز
مرحبا بك سيده لونا
وماله اليه في النهايه قضيه كنباخ الم يكن
امرا
متوقعا وكان يجب على ارمينيا ان تحسب له
حسابا منذ وقت طويل
[موسيقى]
اولا شكرا على الاستضافه
الوضع
واذا كان المقصود به هو الهجره الجماعيه
لم يؤخذ بالحسبان من جانب الحكومه
الارمينيه ولكن
قالوا انهم مستعدون
لقبول اربعين الفا من اللاجئين من غورني
في لحظه ما ولكن الان لدينا وحسب البيانات
الاخيره التي افرج عنها في العاشره مساء
في التوقيت المحلي في التاسعه حسب توقيت
الدوحه وتقول بانه اكثر من ثمانين الفا من
الناس غادروا
الى داخل ارمينيا والحركه النزوح مستمره
عبر الحدود اذا من المحتمل انه في غضونه
بضعه ايام ولو استمر المعدل الحالي كما هو
عليه لن يبقى ارمنا في
على اعتبار ان يعني اذا كان العدد الان 80
الف ومستمر
النزوح عدد سكان الاقليم
120 الفا فقط فبالتالي
هذه القضيه تقول ارمينيا انها
ستجعلها تعيد بناء التحالفات من جديد ما
المقصود بذلك واي التحالفات ستغيرها
ارمينيا
وارمينيا نعم ارمينيا كانت تبعث
بمبشرات منذ فتره من الزمن تنم عن رغبتها
في امتلاك علاقات اقرب مع الغرب
تاريخيا ارمينيا وكانت ما تزال حليفا
لروسيا وهي عضو في كل المنظمات التي
اسستها روسيا للامن والتعاون لكن كما قلنا
ارمينيا تشعر بانها
حليفتها روسيا قد خانتها وتخلت عنها وان
امريكا
تشعر ان روسيا لم تعد راغبه او قادره بعد
اليوم على حمايتها لهذا السبب هي تحاول ان
تبني علاقات وصلات اكثر قوه مع الغرب مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع الولايات المتحده
تحديدا لكن ذلك بعد ضياع كنباخ عليها
بماذا ستفيدها
تلك
العلاقات الغربيه والاوروبيه بعدما انتهت
قضيه كارباخ وعدت الى حضن اذربيجان
نعم اولا
ليس من الصواب ان نقول ان
ارمينيا تحاول ان يكون لها علاقات مع
الغرب الان بعد ان فقدت قراباغ علينا ان
نقول ان السيد نيكول
عندما اصبح رئيسا الوزراء في 2018 بعد
ثوره اعتبر اعتبرت اعتبرتها روسيا بانها
الثوره مدعومه من الغرب روسيا لم يرق لها
فاشلان ابدا وكانت هناك حرب في 2020 عندما
خسرت اربينيا كل الاراضي
التي احتلتها ارمينيا لثلاثين عاما
وتركت منطقه عازله لحمايه
ثم خسر اجزاء من جوردن ايضا
وروسيا كانت الوصيل الوسيط عفوا للتوصل
الى هدنه بين الطرفين كما ان روسيا نشرت
الفين من قواتها كقوات حفظ السلام
ولحمايه ممر لاتشين لان ممر لاتشين مهم
جدا لانه هو الطريق الوحيد ليربط
وكل الامدادات وكل ما يصل الى
ياتي من ارمينيا عبره ولكن اعتبارا من
ديسمبر الماضي
اذربيجان
استطاعته سيطرتي على هذا الممر شكرا
[موسيقى]
الكاتبه الصحفيه المتخصصه في شؤون القوقاز
حدثنا من تبليسي
[موسيقى]
الى تداعيات حديثي حريق الحمدانيه في
العراق حيث اقيمت مراسيم عزائم جماعيه
لاهالي الضحايا واستدعوات لمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن الحادثه وكان المتحدث باسم
وزاره الصحه العراقيه قد قال ان عدد قتل
الحريق بلغ ثمانيه وتسعين بينما تجاوز عدد
الجرحى مئه شخص
[موسيقى]
في الكنيسه جمعهم المصاب يواسي كل منهم
الاخر
في اول قداس يقام بعد حريق قاعه الاعراس
في الحمدانيه ابتهل اهالي الضحايا طالبين
الرحمه لموتاهم سائلين لهم الراحه الابديه
لكن صلاح لم يستطع حضور القداس كان مشغولا
بدفن زوجه اخيه بعد يوم واحد من دفن ابنه
قضوا جميعا في الحريق الحزن على من فقد
يثقل كاهله لكن الاثقل على نفسه انه لا
يعرف شيئا عن مصير زوجته واخ له وزوجته
يقول انهم حضروا زفاف جميعا ثم اختفوا بعد
الحادث يعني معقول البشر ممنوع
يعني ما اتوقع
جمجمه تبقى عظام تبقى اسنان تبقى يعني ما
شفنا كل شي
التعرف على هويات الضحايا امر يؤرق
السلطات المحليه في نينوى فعدد الضحايا
كبير والكادر البشري محدود لهذا ارسلت
بغداد فريقا متخصصا في التعرف على الهويات
لعل امتار صلاح يقطعون الشك باليقين
ويزيدوا تضارب الارقام الرسميه بشان عدد
القتلى والجرحى من حاله الغموض لدى اسر
الضحايا ولهذا الامر اسباب يرى الهلال
الاحمر انها وجيهه حقيقه لا توجد هنالك
احصائيه ثابته الى حد الان لانه هنالك
يعني اعداد متفاوته بسبب نقل الاشخاص الى
المستشفيات مختلفه في منطقه اربيل ودهوك
والموصل لا تجد الملك احصائيه ثابته
[موسيقى]
مقاطع فيديو خرجت الى العالم بعد يومين من
الماساه وثقت اللحظات الاولى للحادث
انتشرت النيران بسرعه كبيره فاجات
الحاضرين فتدافع نحو الخارج لكن بعد فوات
الاوان بالنسبه للكثيرين
تحول هذا الجدار الى لوحه تذكاريه تؤرخ
لضحايا الحريق وسيمر وقت طويل قبل ان
تستجمع هذه البلده الصغيره شتات نفسها
فالفقد كبير والوجع اكبر وغايه منى سكانها
الان محاسبه المسؤولين عن الفاجعه امسيه
ياسين الجزيره الحمدانيه محافظه نينوى
وقد امر رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني بمواصله تفتيش المباني العامه
وقاعات المناسبات والمطاعم والفنادق وفحص
شروط السلامه العامه والاحتياطات واجراءات
الوقايه من الحرائق والحوادث المحتمله
وشدد السوداني خلال زياره للمصادين على
ضروره انزال اقصى العقوبات بمن وصفهم
بالمقصرين والمهملين المتسببين في الحريق
مؤكدا انه لا تسامح مع اي تقصير من اي
موظف حكومي
معنى من الحمدانيه بمحافظه نينوى ومراسله
الجزيره ستير حكيم
فقدنا الاتصال على ما يبدو مع ستار حكيم
سنعود اليها لمتابعه الموقف من هناك عدد
السير حكيم ضعينا في سوره الاوضاع في
الحمدانيه في اليوم الثالث
لحصول هذه الكارثه
انت معنا
سنعود سنعود الى الى ستير حكيم لاستطلاع
الموقف في الحمدانيه اليوم ستير تفضلي
نعم حسن كما يظهر هنا خلفنا لا يزال اهالي
واقرباء من لقوا حتفهم في هذه الحادثه
يتوافدون تباعا الى هذا المكان لايقاد
الشموع
حدادا على ارواح من فقدوهم في هذه الحادثه
التي خلفت عشرات من القتلى والجرحى وايضا
اليوم تم القيامه بعمليه بتشييع ودفن نحو
45 شخصا تم تسليمهم لاسرهم من المستشفيات
ومن السلطات الرسميه وتمت عمليات الدفن
اليوم ومن المقرر ايضا ان يكون يوم غد
هناك دفعه اخرى من هؤلاء لكن ما يشغل باله
هؤلاء وايضا سكان مدينه الحمدانيه واسر
الضحايا هو موضوع التحقيقات الى اين وصلت
وهل سيتم معاقبه الجنات خاصه وان المتحدث
باسم الدفاع المدني
في محافظه نينوى قال لبعض وسائل الاعلام
ان هذه القاعه قاعه الهيثم التي احترقت
ليس لديها رخصه بناء وبالتالي هذه القاعه
بنيت بشكل غير قانوني بشكل كامل وبحسب ما
صرح به ان هذا البناء اساسا بني تحت ابراج
ضغط عاليه بالتالي عاده الحكومه والسلطات
الرسميه وايضا البلديات لا تمنح الرخص لاي
بناء تحت ابراج الضغط العالي بالمقابل
هناك حديث
لاصحاب القاعه لبعض المصادر القريبه من
اصحاب القاعه ان القاعه تم بناؤها بعد
الحصول على موافقات ورخصه مقابل مادي ليتم
غض النظر عن عدم التزامها بالشروط
والضوابط التي عاده تتبع في بناء في اي
ابنيه قانونيه لذلك هناك الان
تتجه الى صحه هذه المعلومات وهل فعلا تم
الحصول على الرخصه وان فعل وان تم فعلا
ذلك لماذا لم يتم بناء هذه القاعه ضمن
الشروط والضوابط بتوفير مثلا منافذ
للطوارئ وايضا اجهزه اطفاء
وربما كان هذه لو كان توفر هذه توفرت هذه
الشروط كان قد تم تفادي سقوط هذا العدد
الكبير من الضحايا وايضا المصابين حكيم من
الحمدانيه شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط مسيره
اوكرانيه في اجواء منطقه بيل غورد غربيه
البلاد من جهه قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
دفاعاته الجويه اعترضت فجر اليوم 34 طائره
مسيره من نوع شاهد من اصل 44
اطلقها الروس باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
واضاف ان قوته خاضت اكثر من 20 اشتباكا مع
القوات الروسيه على مختلف جبهات القتال في
الساعات القليله الماضيه
واقل الجيش الاوكراني انه احرز تقدما
جديدا في محور بخموت باتجاه بلدتي قدره
ديفيكا
وشوميز واضاف ان قوته نجحت في التقدم ايضا
في اتجاه بلده كليشيفكا بعد ان استعاد
السيطره عليها الاسبوع الماضي واشار الجيش
الاوكراني الى انه بات يسيطر ناريا على
جزء من الشارع السريع الرابط بين بلدتي
غورليفكا التي كانت خاضعه لسيطره الموالين
لروسيا ومدينه
في هذه الاثناء اعلن الناطق باسم الرئاسات
الروسيه زياده الانفاق الدفاعي وقال ان
ذلك امر ضروري للغايه لان البلاد تعيش ما
سماها حاله حرب هجينه
[موسيقى]
حذر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مما اعتبره
تهديدا جديدا للديمقراطيه الامريكيه مضيفا
انه تهديد يتعرض له الدستور والمؤسسات
الامريكيه واضاف ايضا في خطاب له بولايه
اريزونا ان هناك حركه متطرفه لا تشارك
الامريكيين معتقداتهم الاساسيه وتتالف من
متشددين من الحزب الجمهوري كما تهم في
الوقت ذاته الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بمحاوله تقويض الدستور والمؤسسات الحكوميه
الامريكيه وبانه يعتقد انه فوق القانون
حسب قوله
وقد عقدت لجنه الرقابه في مجلس نواب
الامريكي اولى جلساتها المتعلقه بالمزاعم
بشان علاقه الرئيس جو بايدن بالانشطه
الماليه لنجله هانتر في مسعا يهدف الى
محاكمته برلمانيا ويتهم مشرعون جمهوريون
بايدن باساءه استخدام منصب حين كان نائبا
للرئيس بهدف تحقيق مكاسب ماليه لعائلته
وكان نواب جمهوريون قد اصدروا مذكره قالوا
فيها انهم حصلوا على الاف الوثائق
المتعلقه بالقضيه وانهم يسعون للوصول الى
سجلات اضافيه بينما يرى النواب
الديمقراطيون ان الجمهوريين لم يعثروا على
دليل يربط الرئيس بالمعاملات الماليه
لنجله ويقولون ان التحقيقات تاثير الدم
على المحاكمه البرلمانيه التي استهدفت
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب خلال فتره
ولايته
معنى من كاليفورنيا رون
نيرنج الرئيس السابق للحزب الجمهوري في
كاليفورنيا ومن بوسطن معنا ديفيد بولغر
المديره السابق لمكتب السنه
ونبدا مع ضيفنا الجمهوري نان
بالسؤال ان كان الجمهوريون يسعون الى ان
تكون هناك محاكمه مقابل محاكمه واتهام
مقابل اتهام بغض النظر عن متانه الادله
والاتهام الموجه
اعتقد الامر اكثر من كونه امر ضد امر لان
سلوك ابن الرئيس هنتر بايدن
وهو لديه مشكلات كثيره هنتر بايدن لديه
مشكلات قانونيه كثيره
وتم توجيه تهم له وفق الادله الموجوده
يبدو ان والد
هنتر بعدين الرئيس بايدن ربما ساعده يساعد
نزله من اجل تمويل اموال لصالح والده او
والده
سهل امر ابنه سواء كان ذلك في النتيجه
سيؤدي الى محاكمه برلمانيه لغرض العزل هذا
ما زال احتمالا بعيدا حتى الان
ولكن يعني في هذه النقطه يعني تقول
المعلومات انه ليس كل الجمهوريين في مجلس
النواب يوافقون على هذه المحاكمه وانها
محاوله من رئيس المجلس فقط لارضاء الاكثر
تشددا المؤيدين للرئيس ترامب فقط
[موسيقى]
اعتقد
التاثيرات المعنويه هذا هو ان الجمهوريين
حولنا يخلق مشكله انا
اؤيد مع الزميلي ران بان هنتر فعلا لديه
بعض المشاكل
[موسيقى]
العام الخاص وزاره العدل يدرسون يحققون في
ذلك هناك مساله هناك من لديه مشاكل في
الفرائف وايضا شراء اسلحه ناريه
وهذا كله شيء جيد ولابد من التحقيق فيه
والعمليه جاريه واما ما يقوم بالكونغرس
مجلس النواب بالذات هو
انهم يريدون
مخاطبه جمهوريين او الجانب اليمين من حزب
الجمهوريه الذي يسمى ماجا الذين يدعمون
ترامب يقول لهم انتم قمتم ذلك مرتين ضد
الرئيس ترامب فنحن اذا سنرد على ذلك ونقوم
به ضد جو بايدن وان ان الكثير من
المحافظين من الجناح اليمني في المجلس
نواب قالوا ذلك منذ سنين
هذا مجرد عرض ومجرد شيء مخجل ولكن هذا
يخرج الى الجمهور بان هيتر هو مشكله وان
جوبا
يرتبط او يساعد الاذن هو زرع بذره تؤثر
على انتخابات 2024
بحيث يقول الناس انهم ماذا عن ابنه لا
اعتقد ذلك سيحقق اي نتيجه ان
ان الجناح اليمين من الجمهوريين
كانوا متحمسين جدا لطرح هذا الموضوع منذ
سنتين
اذا المساله انتخابيه معنويه اكثر منها
واقعيه ما رايك
هذا ليس واضحا بعد حقيقه
بالتاكيد الجمهوريون في مارس النواب
سيسعون الى اثبات وجودي علاقه بين بين
هنتر بايدن ومحاولاته تامين اموال لصالح
والده وايضا ما قام به من مخالفات سواء
كان في عهد والده كرئيس او نائب رئيس هذا
ليس واضحا بعض وكذلك محاوله
باستغلال
موارد ابنه لصالحه طبعا لا توجد محاوله
عزل برلمانيه من دون بعد سياسي وهذه لا
تختلف عن سابقاتها
ماذا لو تمكن الجمهوريون من ايجاد هذا
الربط
بين
هانتر
ووالده الرئيس او نائب الرئيس
انا اتفق مع اعتقد هذا هو ما يحاول ان
يقوم به الجمهوريون
العوده ومراجعه كل السجلات وصولا الى
الفتى التي كانت بها الرئيس نائم للرئيس
اثناء اداره اوباما المحاوله التراب وجود
اي علاقه
بايدن معه هنتر بايدن مع والده سوى الى
الصين او الى الدول الاخرى في العالم
للتوصل الى بعض الاستنتاجات او الربط قد
يكون هناك بعض الامور في هذا الامر وهناك
امكانيه امكانيه حسب رايي ضعيفه جدا ولكن
سننتظر لنرى لتستمر هذه العمليه ولكن ما
يحاولون القيام به هو اساسا هو
ما مررنا به انهاء في السادس
عندما كنا انا وزميلي وعلى مسافه 100 متر
من هذا ما حصل في الهجوم على
الرئيس ترامبول الذي قادر هذا الهجوم على
من بوستين المدير السابق لمكتبه سيناتور
وشكرا لرون نيروج الرئيس السابق للحزب
الجمهوري في كاليفورنيا
[موسيقى]
افادت وكاله استشهدت بان قطر نجحت في
التوسط للتواصل الى تفاهم بين اسرائيل
وغزه لاعاده فتح معبر بيت حنون ايريس
ونقلت عن رئيس اللجنه القطريه لاعاده
اعمار غزه السفير محمد العمادي قبل ان قرر
نجاحات في تهدئه الاوضاع في قطاع غزه من
خلال وساطتها للتوصل الى تفاهم لاعاده فتح
المعبر امام العمال الفلسطينيين
وكانت اسرائيل قد اعلنت اعاده فتح معبر
بيت حنون ايريس شمل قطاع غزه بعد اغلاقه
لاسبوعين
تعمل ايران منذ سنوات على تطوير منصات
محليه للتواصل الاجتماعي لتكون منافسا
للمنصات العالميه التي حجبتها بشكل شبه
كامل منذ احتجاجات العمل الماضي ورغم هذه
المساعي يرى مراقبون ان السلطات الايرانيه
لم تنجح كثيرا في اقناع الجمهور بوسائل
التواصل المحليه وسط تحديات تتعلق بجوده
هذه المنصات وامني بيانات المستخدميها
خارج رقابه السلطه او هكذا يعتقد يلج حامد
تطبيق انستجرام
المحظوره في ايران يفضل صديقه استخدام
البروكسي لدخول المنصات العالميه على
منصات محليه سهله الوصول
الخارجي كيفيه يفضل المنصات العالميه فهي
افضل من حيث الجوده والسرعه اكثر امانا
مع ان شاركها جميع اصدقائي في وسائل
التواصل العالميه ولا ادخلون منصات
الايرانيه الا للتواصل مع المدرسه التي
فرضتها على الطلاب
الانتشار السريع للصور الاحتجاجات العام
الماضي دفع السلطات للتوحكم القبضه على
وصول مواطنيها الى المنصات الاكثر شعبيه
لكن ماذا عن البديل قدمت السلطات منصات
وطنيه
ايتا
وفي سينما بدلا عن واتساب تيليجرام
انستجرام وفيسبوك تحاول المنصات الايرانيه
منافسه نظيراتها الاجنبيه على الجمهور
المحلي لكن مع تقدم واضح لتلك العالميه
في مقر احد اشهر منصات التواصل الايرانيه
عمل دؤوب لتحسين الجوده وجذب اكبر عدد من
المستخدمين تطمئن المنصات المشتركين على
احترام بياناتهم الخاصه بعيدا عن العيون
الامنيه
وتؤكد توفر ميزات منافسه فيها
توفر المنصات الداخليه للمستخدمين
المحادثات والقنوات والمجموعات والبث
المباشره والاتصال بالصوت والفيديو اضافه
الى الدفع الالكتروني ونطمح الى تقديم
خدماتنا حتى خارج ايران
لكن هناك من يشكك في كفاءه هذه التطبيقات
ودوافع اللجوء المواطنين اليها
اجبار
الالزام هو دافع كثيرين للتسجيل في تلك
المنصات فالحكومه تجبر الموظفين والطلاب
على استخدامها لتسيير بعض امورهم كما
يدخلها من لا يمتلكون ثمن البروكسي لم
تنجح من حيث الجوده والكثيرون لا يثقون
بها
ما بين منصات عالميه واخرى محليه يبقى
الخيار للجمهور مهما قدمت السلطات لهم من
مبررات امنيه وسياسيه داخل المنصات
المحليه تلحظ مساعي لسحب الجمهور الايراني
من المنصات العالميه وان نجحت كما تقول في
جذب ملايين المشتركين لكن التحدي هو كسب
مستخدمين نشطينا ودائمي عمر هواش الجزيره
طيران
[موسيقى]
فقره في المتابعه الليله نخصصها لترسانه
كوريا الشماليه النوويه بعد قرار برلمانها
اجلس الشعب الاعلى ادراج سياسه بناء القوه
النوويه ضمن دستور البلاد
يسمح التعديل الدستوري لبنيانغ بتعزيز
قوتها النوويه كما ونوعا لضمان ما سماه
بيان البرلمان حق البلاد في الوجود
والتنميه وردع الحرب وحمايه السلام
الاقليمي والعالمي
تستند تلك الخطوه الى حقيقه امتلاك البلاد
سنه نوويه متطوعه تتضمن ما بين اربعين
وخمسين راسا نوويا حسب جمعيه الحد من
التسلح في الولايات المتحده ووفق جمعيه
الحد من التسلح ايضا فان بحوزتي
مخزونا من المواد الانشطاريه يكفيها
لانتاج سبع قنابل نوويه كل عام كما تتضمن
الترسانه النوويه صواريخ عابره للقارات
مثل صواريخه
ومدى نحو 10000 كيلومتر اضافه الى النسخه
الاكثر تطورا وهي صاروخه وسونغ خمسه عشر
بمدى يصل الى 13 الف كيلو متر وتعتقد
الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان كوريا الشماليه
رغم العقوبات الدوليه المشدده عليها قادره
على تركيب راس نوويا صواريخها العابره
للقارات والتي يمكن ان تصل الساحل الغربيه
الامريكي وهواي والاسكا ايضا والعمل
الماضي اجره
34 اختبارا للاسلحه شملت نحو
80 صاروخا بالاستيا وصاروخ كروز كما نفذ
جيشها تجربه تحاكي هجوما نوويا تكتيكيا
قرار دستره الحاله النوويه لكوريا
الشماليه سبقته خطوات مختلفه عبر السنوات
والعقود الماضيه
فقبل اكثر من 60 عاما اسست ديونج بر
برنامجها النووي ضمن ما سمته حينذاك
التحصين الكليه للبلاد
عام
2003 انسحبت كوريا الشماليه من معاهده عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه التي كانت طرفا
فيها
وفي اكتوبر من عام 2006 اعلنت الدوله
المحاصره اجراء اول تجربه نوويه ناجحه
العام الماضي اقر برلمان كوريا الشماليه
ان البلاد اصبحت رسميا قوه نوويه ولكن دون
تضمين ذلك في الدستور
الان تم تضمين هذا الموضوع في الدستور
وللحديث عنه ينضم الينا من اكسفورد
الدكتور ادوارد
الباحث المختص في شؤون شبه الجزيره
الكوريه والعلاقات الدوليه في شرق اسيا
اذا دستوريا كوريا الشماليه قوه نوويه
ماذا يعني ذلك على ارض الواقع وماذا سيغير
نعم اذا هذا استمرار وامتداد طبيعي لما
رايناه في العقد الماضي حيث تحاول كوريا
الشماليه ان تفرض وجودها كدوله نوويه فعلت
ذلك قبل عشر سنوات نحو ذلك والان
تحاول ان تبين ما هي الشروط التي بموجبها
يمكن لها كدوله ان تستخدم السلاح النووي
اذا هذه هذه الخطوه تتويج لما سبقها من
خطوات فهي تريد الاعتراف بها كدوله نوويه
كامر واقع في العالم وهذا ما يبرز طموحات
كوريا الشماليه انها ليست مجرد طموحات بل
النظام والحكومه
بكل وضوح ان تجعل من هذا واقعا مرئيا
واضحا تمام الوضوح الى اي مدى هذا الامر
يصعب اي تفاوض مع كوريا الشماليه حول
الحد
من اسلحتها النوويه يعني حصل الاجتماع ما
بين وفود
كوريه جنوبيه والولايات المتحده
واليابان من اجل بحث هذا الموضوع وهذه
الوفود كانت وفود تفوضيه الى اي مدى هذا
الامر يعقد المفاوضات
طبعا نحن نعلم ان في الاشهر الثلاثه
الماضيه واذا ما اخذنا بعين الاعتار
اعتبار تصريحات الدوله وخاصه ما جعل لساني
شقيقه الزعيم انها لا تريد حقيقه مفاوضات
وخاصه في ضوء ما تصر عليه واشنطن بان يجب
ان تدخل كوره الشماليه في ايه مفاوضات
بدون شروط في الحقيقه هذا تعنط كوري شمالي
يبين بانها لن تخوض اي مفاوضات المتحده
بغض النظر عن اي تطورات على غرار ما حصل
من قمه في كامب ديفيد بين وحش الطن
وطاقيه وخاصه ان
الولايات
ان كوريا الشماليه ما تزال لديها علاقاتها
مع راعيها من ايام الحرب البارده وهي
روسيا
اذا اردنا ان نسال عن انعكاس هذا الامر
على
الواقع النووي الكوري الشمالي هل سيتغير
شيء على الارض على صعيد زياده هذه القوه
النوويه
ياسمين نعم في ينار 2021 في المؤتمر
الثامن للحزب الحاكم اعلن زعيمهم بانه
لديه قائمه مشتريات باسلحه تقليديه وغير
تقليديه يريد
توفيرها وهذا ما جعل ذلك من في قمه
اولويات السياسه الداخليه لكوريا الشماليه
اذا من المحتمل
المرجح الان ان كره الشماليه لن تزيد فقط
من زياده عدد الروس النوويه بل ستوسع من
نطاق
جودتها تريد الصواريخ افضل
تحلق لمسافات اطول وتبقى في مرحله طائرات
فترات اطول وحمولتها اطول قدراتها
وايضا في قدرتي على حمل الرؤوس النوويه
البحث المختص في شؤون الجزيره الكوريه
والعلاقات الدوليه في الشرق اسيا حدثنا من
اوكسفورد شكرا لك
انتهى الحصاد لهذه الليله الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]